you do loads of action don't you diddly
and of course you have done action
before in things like Barnack woman was
it like getting really physical again it
was great I was completely out of shape
when I first started on the set I was
like oh gosh I should have done a little
more training here
but it very quickly came back and using
the weapons was kind of second nature
Jack was sort of like oh look at you and
I was like well I do know how to handle
a gun and then when we got to sort of
doing all the fighting the zombies you
know I knew how to kick and and it was
quite it was quite easy and it was great
to get physical again I think it's it's
um I just love that element of my my job
I get to that physicality in a way your
character she's very fine since she kind
of treated a little bit like one of the
lads and she well I think I have a real
tomboy outside to me I grew up with lots
of cousins and I was always the eldest
so there is a little bit of that leader
they'll probably say it's bossiness
but with Katie she is a real ball
breaker and she is she doesn't suffer
fools gladly and with her cousins she
felt that need to come in and help so I
think you know she likes the element of
chaos and I did actually find it really
fun to dress up as the Builder and I
actually did this funny walk which I
thought was a real like boys walk and
the director cut it my was like all the
girls on set really loved it because it
was just sort of bit I think for them
the energy of the piece they didn't say
they need the scene now you slipped back
into that company the eastern to accent
the descent you did it bring back
memories that when you're in EastEnders
and did you find it easy to pick it up
again it was actually again like the
physical stuff I thought oh this will be
easy and then the first day I was like
ah this is I'm not so fluently as I used
to be but you didn't take long to slip
back in like with the physical side of
it with some great iconic scenes as well
as one where you're on a big old
double-decker bus I think the last hour
they are so young effective October
service for Doctor Who on a bus doing
sighs by playing these characters I'm
wearing black and yeah there is a theme
to all of this I think they bring back
memories for you when you did that with
David Tennant it did actually always
kind of like I'm on a bus again it's not
often that you get a character this you
know
that goes off in a bus my guess is
London is very London buses and you
working with actor Ashley Thomas again
actor and musician Ashley Thomas well I
work with him on a zombie film and an
actor who was going to play the lead in
the madness I pulled out and I said
Ashley get your agent to send you there
so have you seen it and the director had
him in mind as well and I was just like
he is gonna be he would perfect so so
yeah it was great to work with him again
and you've got lots of things good one
of which is cabaret and the West End
it's now you're looking forward to that
I can't wait it's been a great rehearsal
period we're coming to the end of it now
will is lovely all of the cars -
brilliant
the creative team are fantastic and I
just yeah I can't wait to go on tour and
then come back to London I think it's
going to be a really great experience
singing and dancing something that comes
naturally to you yes I have to be honest
it was what I did when I was young girls
putting on shows at home and then I went
to a local drama group and did all of
the ballet jazz to have every dance
imaginable then I worked at kind of a
dance studios and took lots of classes
there and I had to sing in the man
inside so in the last two years I've got
that back up to scratch and with this
sort of singing so yeah it's something
but I think it's like the action it's
like an extension of the character and I
think it just enhances what you do
really and finally is it is it really
important for you to be working in
British theatre and British film and TV
and what does it mean to you and as an
as an actress as a British actress I
think it is important what's been really
nice since I come back from the States
is finding these really great projects
that in a way Sally Bowles was a British
you know a British character and with
the zombie film
the man is site that things that are are
kind of so true to London life so it's
been great I mean that being said it's
it's great to sort of travel and see the
world but there is something about
working with Peter Mullan and Rufus
Norris that is you know is something
really I'm really pleased to be doing
but ideally what would be next after
cabaret right I think I'm just thinking
about the opening night the first night
of a Savoy that's my focus right now
beyond that I'm really happy to just see
what happens because I feel like I've
had a good run and it feels like Lots is
changing in a good way so who knows what
I'll be doing next lots of their
companies versus on with this fantastic
film and she'll be Brighton cabaret -
thank you very much
you